[Music]
hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
so everyone and their dog are playing
apex legends at the moment it's
free-to-play so it's definitely worth
trying the character you choose impacts
both your playstyle and team synergy so
let's quickly break down the original
og8 characters because all we need to
see is that victory screen by the way
the next video in the series will look
at the perfect character combination to
play us in a team but for now let's just
get the basics together let's start with
Bangalore a weapons specialist and is
the typical soldier class you're used to
from pretty much every other game a
great starting character Bangalore's
passive ability is double time this
means if she is shot at whilst running
she'll receive a speed boost for a small
period of time basically moving around
in battle moving to cover in a gunfight
is far quicker with Bangalore her active
abilities complement this skill
massively launching smoke to remain
concealed when repositioning or you
could use this to cover the enemy and
close the gap quickly her ultimate is
effectively a carpet bomb an air strike
from above it can decimate squads and
completely bewildered the opposition if
you're new to Apex legends I suggest
starting with Bangalore meet Wraith this
young lady has interdimensional skills
at her fingertips her passive ability
lets her concience talk to her and we'll
tell you when enemies are nearby this is
a bloody fantastic skill if you're a
player who tends to let their guard down
when looting greatest voice in her head
we'll let you know when to get your game
face back on race also has the ability
to become seemingly invisible for a
short period of time face shifting into
the void the real power of the void is
that Wraith takes no damage in this form
and finally her ultimate the greatest
way to reposition using a portal known
as a dimensional rift and of course it
can be used by your whole squad let's
move on to characters with very
different skill sets
this is bloodhound a hunter who can
track enemies naturally such as noticing
footprints on the ground and the
direction they are going this is taken
up a notch with his first active ability
I of the all-father which for a brief
time allows bloodhound to see everything
on the battlefield enemy positioning and
traps are included in the right scenario
this character is on play
his ultimate takes us one step further
as he becomes the predator our senses
are heightened and you move so damn fast
it's bloody frightening next up is a
defensive character meet Gibraltar
standing it's six foot four and weighing
in at 265 pounds hang on I'm 6 foot 4
and 265 pounds time to go on a diet
anyway so Gibraltar is a big lad but
don't worry he has a great passive
ability to prevent taking shots a
front-facing shield when aiming down
sights his first ability allows him to
throw down a shield like a bauble
perfect for resurrecting teammates in a
long-range battle but just beware the
shield is only viable for 15 seconds
Gibraltar has an ultimate similar to
Bangalore an airstrike but this one is
more cluster based the next character is
a combat medic named lifeline a support
class with insane medical skills
passively lifeline can heal a downed
teammate 25% faster than any other
character and she does this from behind
a shield for cover - that little robot
by her side is called the drone of
compassion and can be set up as a
healing station mid firefight as long as
your teammate stays close enough a Ted
that will join the two together
lifelines ultimate is a beast and
airdrop care package filled with goodies
for your entire squad just beware of
other teams ambushing you when your
guard is down if you don't like human
beings have a look at Pathfinder a
former worker bot that's now a
militarized weapon his skill set is all
about mobility and intelligence
gathering his passive ability allows
Pathfinder to use these beacons to see
the next ring location allowing your
squad to get there early on all the
direction all the other squads will be
pushed his first active ability is a
freaking grappling hook Pathfinder has
far more verticality than any other
character and the icing on the cake is
his ultimate a zipline for squad rushes
or maybe for running away
I mean repositioning once you've played
enough you'll be able to unlock two
additional characters and of course
there's loads more coming in the future
this one is caustic his skillset is
completely based around gas it's like my
girlfriend caustic can place down 6 gas
canisters which can be activated by
bullet damage are set off by enemy
movement it can be close to impossible
to see enemies within that gap
which is where caustic has are some
passive abilities first the gas masks
and armor he wears makes him immune to
the gas and he can also see through that
gas and predict potential enemy attacks
finally my favorite class in the game
Mirage Mirage is a magician on the
battlefield he can send out a decoy
version of himself regularly and can
cause the opposition to follow the wrong
target tactically sending out a
duplicate has so many uses so let's try
and make a video about the best ways to
take advantage of this skill anyway
mirages ultimate is designed to use this
in tricky situations creating a but turn
of decoys and simultaneously cloaking
the real Mirage to allow him to escape
or reposition here's a cool thing to
know - if Mirage is knocked down
he'll automatically drop a decoy and
hide himself for five seconds hopefully
long enough not to get thirsted so there
we go that's all eight characters to
have a go at who do you players at the
moment I'll never forget Bangalore I got
my first win with her anyway we know
there's going to be loads more Legends
added in the future but as the starting
point I think we're done here
I'm Adam from Playstation grenade if you
want to get in touch with me do so by a
Twitter my name is Adam grenade and we
have a discard two and I'm looking for
apex legend mentors to help other people
it's been a pleasure I'll see you next
time
[Music]